[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la côte caribéenne colombienne
elle s'étend sur plus de 1500
km de la frontière du Panama jusqu'à du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Venezuela des plages de sable blanc une
biodiversité unique la trè plus grande
barrière de corail au
[Musique]
[Rires]
monde
[Musique]
il est une spécialité à montpox
difficile à découvrir au premier coup
d'œil derrière ces murs travaillent en
silence des artisans joaliers ils sont
les dignes héritiers de l'époque
coloniale celle où l'or et l'argent
étaient entreposés ici avant d'être
envoyé en
[Musique]
Europe
ce savoir-faire les habitants veillent à
[Musique]
l'entretenir dans cette école les élèves
apprennent l'art du filigrane celui de
des bijou
[Musique]
délicats jossimar est professeur dans
cette établissement depuis près de 5
ans il faut que tu mettes bien les
petites parties à
l'intérieur le setient en étirant les
fil d'argent les Arabes l'Avent enseigné
au conquistad espagnol qui l'ont apporté
avec eux en Amérique du
[Musique]
Sud vous voyez sur toutes nos créations
on y ajoute un accessoire comme celui-ci
pour les transformer en boucle
d'orees bijou sont revendu jusquà 150
dollars pièces selon leur poid chaque
boucle d'oreille chaque médaillon chaque
brcelet est conçu comme un tableau
composé de fil d'argent décliné à partir
d'un modèle de base chaque pièce est
unique Anderson apprend à faire fondre
le
[Musique]
métal il que tu cette pièce que tout
plusun rés il doit
ren C artisan fait partie de mon
histoire et je trouve
deavaer c'est une fté d'apprendre cette
technique si difficile ça serait
vraiment une grande fierté de retrouver
mes
bij ici on ne veut
pas c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est auour' prs de or travaill encore
l'argent et l'or comme le fais les
premiers colons espagnolima
toujours en
exer les je je vous
présente vous allez pouir échanger
acquun
qui
vous devez être des ingénieurs du
f vous devez pratiquer tous les jours
pour arriver à faire une
figurine vous allez être des
génies vous devez l'être parce que vous
aimez
[Musique]
ça moi
j'adore c'est quelqu'un de votre famille
qui vousis la technique
j'ai presque tout appris tout
seul quand j'étais jeune j'ai rencontré
un maître
d'orf je n'arrêtais pas de le regarder
un jour il m'a dit prends les
instruments et
débrouilleimon VEVA appris ce métier
dans les années 80 alors que la Colombie
traversait une grave crise
économique la ville avait tro choses son
histoire sa Semaine Sainte et l'art du
filigrane c'est pour ça que je vous le
dis les enfants il faut que vous vous
[Applaudissements]
accrochiez je ne vais jamais réussir à
lui ressembler car lui c'est vraiment un
mare ni même à faire des pièces aussi
belles j'aimerais vraiment me rapprocher
le plus possible de ce qu' fait
[Applaudissements]
vie j'aime tellement le
Fig je crois que j'aime ça plus que ma
propre
vieette tradition a permis à mon d'être
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Abel le musicien répète avec
sa troupe créée il y a 10 ans
[Musique]
ed sabe que la
danza Siembra aujourd'hui nous allons
jouer la danse des
paysans c'est un hommage à tous les
travailleurs des ch le les indignes les
Africains et les
Espagnols la troupe s'entraîne pour le
défilé du carnaval de Montp qui aura
lieu demain des festivités qui célèbr
l'indépendance de la
Colombie est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chorégraphe
[Applaudissements]
il faut bien balancer ton cor deux côtés
il faut bien bouger les hanch et
[Musique]
[Rires]
surtout un r que les
[Musique]
pay elle a été choisie pour ouvrir le
défilé du
carnaval
monore que t
idené
es un
[Musique]
géné
pendant la semaine du Carnaval les
maisons se transformment en atelier de
[Musique]
couture
et voici nos robes traditionnell on doit
y ajouter ce voile pour qu'elles ait un
peu plus de poids Dar
P
[Musique]
volum siempre ha trabajado cono para
sostener a la
familia
[Musique]
fam Angélica la mère de Ch vit seule les
nuits sont courtes la semaine qui
précède le carnaval il faut que tout
soit prêt en temps et en
[Musique]
he
voici mon lieu de travail mon atelier de
couture aujourd'hui c'est elle qui
confectionne les robes de toutes les
écoles de danse de la
ville quand elle m'a dit qu'elleim la
danse folclorique qu'elle voulait danser
et porter des costumes j'étais
vraiment J'ai fabriqué ces premières Rob
elle tellement les
en fait c'est comme si ma fille avait
réalisé mon
rêve qu
la dan ça
te danser ça peut te faire oublier tous
tes
problèmes peut te
libérer c'est quelque chose que je ne
peux pas
expliquer non je peux pas l'exliquer
mais c'est vraiment vraiment très
[Musique]
beau le défilé va commencer dans
quelques heures
igncio et sa troupe se préparent et
c'est bien sûr angéc qui a confectionné
leur costume
[Applaudissements]
Mira africana Campesina africana
campesinos African ces enfants sont
déguisés en petits paysans
africains ils sont habillés en espagnol
mais ils vont danser sur des rythmes
[Applaudissements]
africains
uabes pourre les graines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
àteruj le bton TR le sol que la
PL la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
planta
c'est le plus ancien carnaval de
Colombie il existe depuis 3 siècles Abel
et son groupe se préparent durant toute
[Rires]
l'année ces énormes têtes en papier
mâché qui émergent parmi les
carnavaliers caricaturent les anciens
maîtres d'autres personnages défilent
comme les pilones des races les Comè sur
les champs de canne à sucre elles
étaient connues pour leur bavardage et
la dénonciation des pratiques des colons
elles font aujourd'hui partie du
patrimoine historique des
[Musique]
Caraïbes
avec Abel en tête de cortège le défilé
peut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
commencer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
aujourd'hui on fait la liberté des
peuples indigènes et africains c'est une
fête très émouvante on est heureux
d'être libre vive
l'Amérique una fiesta que nos llena de
alegría como Libertad que somos Viva
[Musique]
América
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Manz
notre voyage se poursuit jusqu'à la
région de Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta
la plus haute montagne côtière du monde
elle borde la mer des
[Musique]
Caraïbes à ses pieds le parc de teronard
s'étend sur 15000 hectares cette zone a
été le théâtre d'une guerre sanglante
pendant près d'un demi-siècle les forces
révolutionnaires de Colombie les FARC et
les paramilitaires se sont entretué dans
cette
jungle laissant derrière eux des
milliers de victimes la paix est revenue
il y a 3 ans et les touristes
[Musique]
aussi
c'est un énorme nid de
termite pour nous que nous avons en
Autriche sont noir et bien PE ici il y a
des fourmis à bois comme celle-ci elle
est énorme c'est fascinant toutes ces
couleurs comme de nombreux touristes ce
couple va traverser le parc seul et sans
guide en on toujours des histoires sous
le niveau de criminalité qui existerait
en Colombie tout le monde pense que
c'est dangereux de vir
oui tout le monde connaît l'histoire des
farques tout a débuté dans les années 60
ils ont commencé à tourner à la drog aux
États-Unis puis la Guer du narcotrafic a
éclaté ça a vraiment affecté la
[Musique]
Colombie les FARC se sont d'abord
présentés comme les défenseurs des
paysans pauvres avant de s'associer au
narcotrafiquant dans les années
80 retranché dans les zones montagneuses
comme la Sierra Nevada la prise d'otage
devient le arme de
[Musique]
guerreri B encour est l'une de leur plus
célèbres
prisonnière en novembre 2016 un accord
de paix est signé mettant fin à plus
d'un demisècle de
conflit toute la région Rena
aujourd'hui après 3h de marche le couple
d'Autrichien arrive sur la plage de la
piscina au cœur du parc
[Applaudissements]
terona on a réussi on l'a
fait c'est fatiguant mais le paysage
récompense tous nos efforts ça vaut
vraiment le coup c'est le
paradis ça fait du bien l'eau n'est pas
très froide mais un petit peu quand même
juste ce qu'il
[Applaudissements]
faut c'est pour moi une des dernières
grandes aventures que la planète à
offrir j'espère que la jeune génération
aura plus d'opportunités grâce au
tourisme qui se développe il y a de plus
en plus d'infrastructur qui sont en
train de se construire il faut qu'ils
arrivent à gérer cette transition et que
le tourisme garde seulement un impact
[Applaudissements]
positif
même les villages les plus reculés se
sont retrouvés pris en éto entre les
violences des paramilitaires et celles
des mouvements de Guera comme ces
villageois les indigènes kojies qui ont
bien failli disparaître leur terre été
convoitée par les narcotrafiquants les
kojis sont une des grandes civilisation
précolombienne du continent ils cétait
un demimillion avant l'arrivée des
colons espagnols il ne serait plus que
12000 aujourd'hui replié dans les hautes
vallées de la Serra
[Musique]
Nevada
plus bas d'autres villages comme celui
de Minka ont choisi quant à eux de
s'ouvrir au visiteurs étrangers c'est
ici que se retrouent tous ceux qui
explorent la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Nevada depuis l'accord de paix les
auberges poussent comme des champignons
le tourisme se développe et les
étrangers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'installent Chand DOA est américaine
avec son petit ami manuel ils ont créé
cette école de langue pour former les
habitants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir je vais vous donner un cours sur
les
directionsre l'anglais
à
la majorité des investisseurs sont
étrangers si les locaux n'apprennent pas
l'anglais ça va être difficile pour eux
de trouver une place dans cette nouvelle
économie c'est pour cela que nous avons
décidé de créer cette école s'ils
veulent ouvrir un établissement
touristique ou organiser des excursions
désormais ils nurontac de
Laue de paix les habitants n'avaient
aucun contact avec l'extérieur aucune
opportunité de parler
[Musique]
l'anglais a veces veo turistas que Van
en el
bus je vois souvent des touristes qui
descendent du bus ou qui se baladent je
veux leur parler mais je reste bloqué
parce que je ne peux pas l'autre jour
j'ai rencontré une dame qui était perdue
et je n'ai pas pu l'aider ça m'a fait
tellement mal rien faire c'est pour ça
que je vaux apprendre
l'anglais apprendre les directions ça va
vous être super utile ça arrive souvent
que des touristes demandent le chemin et
vous répondez sans comprendre je sais
pas c'est par
[Applaudissements]
là moi je des fruits
erd
VI il va vous falloir de la force et de
la volonté pour continuer à pratiquer
chez vous si vous croisez des touristes
par exemple dans la rue n'ésitez pas à
leur
parler j'espère vous revoir tous la
semaine prochaine pour puiss continuer à
apprendre ensemble merci
beaucoup c'est bon nous sommes
prêts
byeeci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à les habitantsett tout douc traumtisme
du conflit pendant des décennies ils ont
vécu dans la peur des FAR et des
paramilitaires leur mode de vie n'a pas
changé seu la peur a
disparu les familles de M vivent et
travaillent dans ces fermes agricoles
Chea s'est installé chez la famille de
manuel il y a quelques
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
années
j'ai demandé à mes amis en colomie se
trou la montagne la plus proche ils mont
tous envoyé à et je suis tombé amoureuse
de l'endroit de son
histoire mais oui c'est le plus
important et 2 ans et demi plus tard me
voici en train de préparer le
Soch
le sanochon un ragou venu des îles
Canaries espagnoles pendant la
colonisation c'est le plat populaire de
la
[Musique]
région on doit préparer la viande les de
porc le
pou on cuisine le SO avec du manoc du
maïs
maama pltanos
verdurasd de
laadas souvenir sont un des débiles pour
la famille de Manuel pendant le conflit
de habitants duame sont mors Vic de B
perduue un trauma bastante grande vraent
trumtis c'était de vrais barbares des
assassins il tu comme ça gratuitement on
pensait que c'était finion
all c'était
[Musique]
difficile ont commencé à sortir les gens
de chez eu
prend moi à l'époque j'étais avec mon
bébé mon fils on est rest caché dans la
maison
dernière est como fueron
construaso
ti
gr
4ch de Barro y eso protegió mucho
entonces la cama es
queend que les choses ch et enfin arrivé
heureusement on
[Musique]
peut venez vous asseir qu'est-ce que
c'est bon c'est délicieux c'est vraiment
réussi C Favec
amour l'année qui a suivi la signature
de l'accord de paix 6 millions de
touristes se sont rendus en
Colombie notre voyage se termine au
large à 700 km du loral sur l'archipel
des sress une réserve mondiale de la
biosphère
classé par
[Musique]
l'Unesco ces 32 km de barrière de
coraille fond d'elle une des plus
longues du
[Musique]
monde plus proche des Antilles d'Haïti
et de la
que des terres colombiennes 700
colombiens y vivent pourtant à la
croisée des
cultures
[Musique]
com l'archipel est préservé mais le
tourisme n'en est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
exclu
plusieurs centaines de visiteurs
débarquent chaque jour comme ce couple
de
Brésiliens je sais pas si ça va se voir
dans ma vidéo mais la couleur de l'eau
c'est
[Applaudissements]
incroyable ça c'est la joie vous allez
ressentir maintenant Kevin organise des
tours en bateau pour une vingtaine
d'euros ils vont visiter de îos de
l'archipel avant de descendre du bateau
vous pouvez enlever vos chaussures s'il
vous plaît en moins de 10 ans le nombre
de visiteurs a doublé 1 million chaque
année il y a des touristes du monde
entier qui viennent ici d'Europe
d'Amérique et de tous les pays
d'Amérique latine tout ce monde que vous
voyez c'est comme ça tous les
[Applaudissements]
jours
j'aimerais enregistrer ce moment pour la
vie aussi bleu j'ai jamais rien vu d'I
ça n'existe vraiment
[Applaudissements]
N
l'au est tellement chaude j'ai la
sensation d'entrer dans une
[Applaudissements]
P ils sont
petitou pas
po
me j'ai essayé d'en attraper un mais ils
sont très
rapides il y a une variété d'espèces
incroable sur l'archipel les hôtels à
prix se sont multipli les bateaux et les
déchet par les touristes derrièrex sont
aujourd'hui une menace pour
l'écosystème
[Applaudissements]
historiquement l'archipel a toujours été
très convoité pendant plus de de siècles
les Anglais les Espagnols et même les
Français on revendi à tour de rôle la
possession jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
rattaché à la
Colombie s Andr l' principale a réussi à
garder son authenticité et sa culture
affrantillèse ici on parle aussi bien
espagnol anglais que
créole job SAS est un ilen pur sououche
ici c'est une véritable star il chante
dans le groupe de réget les plus
populair de l'île et comme tous les
habitants il jongle lui aussi d'une
langue à
[Applaudissements]
l'autre vous avez quoi comme poisson
aujourd'hui
ici ce qui est génial c'est qu'on peut
avoir des produits
frais que ce soit des produits qu'on
cultive à la ferme ou pche c'est
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
fra on peut juste les manger on peut pas
les vendre car ce sont
[Applaudissements]
des
ch c'est une tradition qui VI
ANC les esclaves africains qui ont été
amenés ici par les
ESP
te la chance de'ir toi et ton
[Rires]
poiss
[Applaudissements]
job repartira avec plusieurs kilos de
poisson frais pour seulement une
vingtaine
[Musique]
d'euros il se prépare à recevoir ses
amis pour le déjeuner vit dans ce décor
de rêve une ferme tropicale c'est ici
qu'il habite avec sa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
femme je vais récupérer des Bosc c'est
une sorte de banane
pltin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant je récupère des fruits à
pain tout ça c'est pour cuisiner le
Randon notre plat
[Musique]
traditionnel
test
micro job a créé son propre groupe de Ré
avec ses amis il y a déjà 20
ans nous on fait du saint Andr musque
c'est du
biologique c'est fait avec des sentim
[Musique]
naturel
cette musique c'est l'illustration de
notre
légèreté a des Bones vibration car vous
savez c'est ce qu'on essaie d'exprimer
dans notre
[Musique]
musique
dans les années 50 pendant la dictature
le gouvernement met en place une
politique de peuplement à s Andr il
encourage les Colombiens à s'installer
sur l'île et l'espagnol devient la
langue officielle les habitants
craignent la disparition de leur
identité affrtillaise et de leur
particularité culturelle comme la langue
créole et la musique des mouvements
séparatistes afro naiss mar en fait
partie ce qu'on raconte dans nos
chansons c'est qu'on est très fier de
notre identité
insulaire notre culture notre couleur et
nos
[Musique]
origines souvent les gens du continent
veulent ner ce que nous sommes mais
quand tu n'as pas ta propre identité tu
peux te perdre nous on sait qui on est
et on le revendique en
chanson
[Musique]
le random qu'il prépare c'est le plat
des esclaves transmis de génération en
génération la gardienne de la recette
celle qu' l' transmise à son Petitfils
c'est la grand-mère de
[Musique]
Job ce platpique se cuisine avec du
poisson des fruits de mer avec des
bananes
planttinoc et tout ça va jet dans du
lait de
coco le
r C'est devenu le plat de toute une
communauté celle des RAL
[Musique]
afrotill
ici nous n'avons pas de farine mais le
fruit à pain c'est notre pain à
nous tout est traditionnel
ici même la façon d'allumer le feu on
nutilise pas de kérosène pas d'essence
tout est
naturel tout est fait maison même laoc
la noix é séché puis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ré
moi je parle en créol c'est ça mon
langage je m'identifie à donc je parle
la des Africains qui
ét
[Musique]
ma grand-mère adorit cuisiner ce plat m
les jours et elle dit très
[Musique]
[Rires]
forte Notre culture c'est celle des
carïbes il n aucun
doute ce sont de multiples influences
qui son
spécial
[Musique]
nous avons des origines
indigèes mais nous sommes aussi le fruit
de la colonisation
angl
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
espag ce mélange de culture produit un
goût
délicieux un AR légerû
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'identité afroocaribéenne est en train
de devenir une véritable marque de
fabrique depuis 2 ans il existe même une
chaîne de télévision qui lui est
spécialement
dédié
[Applaudissements]
ent c'est vraiment important parce que
nous sommes très loin du continent donc
cette chaî nous permet d'avoir un
contact avec le reste du
monde pu le reste du monde peut rester
en contact avec nous et savoir ce qu'il
se passe sur
l'île est originaire de Providencia une
des î de l'archipel depuis 2 ans elle
présente cette émission de
mode
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer un
nouveau
style une nouvelle façon de coiffer vos
cheveux comment dresser vos boucles avec
de la
mousse regardons le
[Musique]
résultat ici on parle de la beauté
afroaribne
éci nous réunissons les tendances des
îles des Caraïbes que ce soit celle de
la Jamaïque des antillesou des autres
territoes notre manière d'être notre
joie de vivre nos différents styles de
coiffure avec des couleurs de cheveux
originales c'est vraiment propre à notre
identité Caribes c'est ça qui nous
différenci et c'est qui nous lit entre
peuple des
carïbes on revient dans quelques
instants merci à tous
sur cette île d'à peine 50 km de long
règne une ambiance toute jamaïcaine très
décontractée avec forcément du soleil
toute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'année au bord des routes les bars à
musique régé se succède les habitants
passent après leur journée de travail le
bar préféré d' c'est celui de dixio un
petit fils d'imigré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamaïcain
[Musique]
comment ça
va
ok je suis super contente de te
voir c'est dans les années 60 pendant
les débuts Dué en Jamaïque que ce style
musical est arrivé
[Musique]
jusquicié sur l'Î par des pêcheurs et
des marins
il amené des vinimes de Jamaïque et de
différents endroits des
Caraïbes ça été l'un des premiers
courants musical
ici mais on avait aussi d'autres
genenses du Sou Soka du calypso aussi tu
peux aller dans n'importe quel lî des
Caraïbes même sur la côte colombienne tu
trouveras toujours un bar de reg c'est
le sole de notre vie
relaxe
[Musique]
dans quelques heures job et son groupe
vont jouer au Green Moon Festival toute
la ville est là et même les habitants
des îes voisines ont fait le
déplacement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de nombreux artistes reprennent les
genres traditionnels de la région le et
bien sûr le
ré
[Musique]
Annie la présentatrice est là aussi
toute la soirée sera retransmise en
direct sur la télévision
local cet événement c'est comme une
plateforme pour connecter toutes les
populations
caribéenes on a des groupes qui viennent
de toutes les Caraïbes de Jamaïque
trinid Tobago du Royaume-Uni aussi car
il a une grande communauté à dans ces
pays tout ça c'est pour enrichir notre
diaspora çaarrive qu'une seule fois par
an donc il faut qu'on en
profite au-delà de l'aspect culturel cet
événement une résonance mondiale on va
développer le tourisme au niveau
[Musique]
international a tour de job de monter
sur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
festival
[Musique]
merci merci c'était
[Applaudissements]
super ta PL le
spectacle cont je Suiss
cont je suis heureux
aussi ce soir on a lutté pour la culture
du peuple afro des Caraïbes on leur a
montré que ce sont des
rois et qu' y a des talents uni
[Applaudissements]
ici c'était vraiment amusant quand je
vous regardais danser je me disais
qu'est-ce qu'es ont d'énergie et moi
quand j'étais perdu je regardais
simplement
les je suis juste très inspiré je suis
rythme à partir de maintenant on va
pouvoir se connecter entre le peuple des
Caraïbes on va se réunir et on va
grandir tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]